Donald Trump is, uh, what in the world of
poker or chess, we call on tilt because of
the widespread reporting of these truly terrible
polling numbers that have been released over
the last 10 days or so. And I'll remind you
once again, according to Donald Trump's own
internal polling and public polls, as of right
now, Donald Trump is losing badly in some
key 2020 battleground states. He's fired some
pollsters just reported that to you in the
last story. He's called the pulse fake. He's
done everything under the sun to try to suppress
the news of those polls, but now he is even
calling Fox News fake news. This is getting
very, very interesting. Bret Baier on Fox
News did something which is not really a huge
deal. Bret Baier just reported what the polls
are saying, including this new Fox News poll
that I told you about yesterday, which says
Trump is down by nine to Bernie and by 10
to Joe Biden in hypothetical 2020 matchups.
And because Bret Baier merely said, we did
a poll and here's what it says, Donald Trump
immediately took to Twitter and attacked Bret
Baier for spreading fake news tweeting Fox
News polls are always bad for me. That's not
true by the way. They were against Crooked
Hillary. Also something weird going on at
Fox. Our polls show us leading in all 17 swing
states. That's also a lie for the record,
I didn't spend 30 hours with ABC News, but
rather a tiny fraction of that more fake news.
Bret Baier. So there are a couple of things
going on here on one of them is exactly as
I predicted months ago and this is something
serious that we have to talk about so that
we all understand it. Many of you, if you've
been watching this program for awhile or listening
to the radio show or podcast, you know that
sometimes on Fox News, Shepard Smith or Chris
Wallace will say something moderately rational.
They'll tell some basic uncontroversial truth.
They'll counter some obvious bogus right wing
talking point. And it really shouldn't be
a huge deal when someone on the news just
tells the truth. But on Fox News it sort of
is a big deal because it is such a disinflation
echo chamber. So when I talk about it on the
show, I will say it's good that Shepard Smith
told the truth. It's good that Chris Wallace
told the truth, but it's a very low bar and
we have to understand that it's very limited
opposition to an overall narrative that is
extraordinarily pro Trump on Fox News. And
the danger is that these little instances
of sanity on Fox can also open the door for
Fox to say, hey look, we are fair and balanced.
We have multiple views represented, we have,
uh, almost everything. And then on the other
hand, every once in awhile, Shep Smith is
allowed to say something that's true.
Now, it's absurd since a reporter Shep Smith,
for example, stating a fact shouldn't be considered
a balancing of the rampant right wing xenophobic
propaganda that Fox is riddled with, but it
does sort of opened the door for Fox to take
some cover under the fact that they have shep
Smith and Chris Wallace. Now along the same
lines, when Donald Trump calls Bret Baier
fake news, uh, or at least Bret Bayer's report
fake news that can similarly be used to prop
fox up as, hey, they're also getting slammed
by Trump. Fox is no different. They are under
the microscope by Trump, just like CNN and
everybody else instead of the fact the real
facts, the reality that the right wing echo
chamber propaganda network of Fox News is
99% propaganda. And as I said a few months
ago, depending on how 2020 goes, Fox News
could abandon Trump. Fox News is of course
committed to being right wing because that's
what their donors and their funders demand
and expect.
They are right wing. They will continue to
be right wing, but Fox News is not necessarily
committed to Donald Trump. Fox, you might
remember back in 2016 really in 2015 when
the campaign started, Fox was not behind Donald
Trump. Early in the 2016 Republican primary.
There were some big conflicts between Fox
and Trump early on. Now, eventually when it
became clear that Donald Trump had growing
support, that more and more of the Republican
establishment was getting behind Donald Trump
even be grudgingly. In some sense, Fox ultimately
got behind Donald Trump. If Trump continues
to be an utter and total embarrassment on
the world stage, but it looks like he's going
to win reelection in 2020 Fox will stay behind
him, but if it looks like Trump will fail
as some early polls suggest, he might. Fox
News is not necessarily going to stick with
Trump. They're about profit and right wing
propaganda.
In a general sense, Trump might be the vehicle
for that propaganda, but he also might not.
And just to prepare you, if Trump and fox
have a falling out, you need to know that
Donald Trump's network of choice is going
to become this absolutely whacked out thing
called o a n the one America News Network
or one American use. Check it out online,
but not with kids in the room and not close
to meal times because it is truly, it'll,
it'll turn your stomach. Uh, but o a n is
where Trump will go if ultimately he abandons
Fox News as the propaganda vehicle of choice.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at Davis Dot.
Pacman and while you're there, follow the
fell on Instagram as well at David Pakman
show. We will take a quick break for you.
It's a good program today,